- Let me get this straight,
I park where I'm not
supposed to,
and that gives you the right
to punch my fucking car?
[screaming]
[dark electronic music]
♪
- [growls]
- [panting]
[gears compressing]
[mechanical feedback]
♪
[cheers and applause]
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening".
I'm the host, Ari Shaffir,
and tonight
the topic is "melee."
[cheers and applause]
Ladies and gentlemen,
you know him from
the amazing podcast
"We'll See You In Hell."
Please give it up
for my friend and yours,
Mr. Joe DeRosa.
[cheers and applause]
- I don't care for
the way people act...
these days,
most of the time.
I don't like the way
people act.
Uh, I find everybody to be
very entitled.
Nobody apologizes anymore.
Nobody says, "Sorry."
Sorry isn't an apology anymore.
Sorry has become
a sarcastic phrase.
It's completely sarcastic now,
'cause everybody's entitled,
you know,
"Sorry, I'm a bitch. Sorry."
Deal, I'm a bitch."
Well, you're a cunt,
actually.
You're a cunt
and a horrible person.
Uh, but that's everybody's
attitude.
Like, "Deal, ugh--ugh--ugh"
and it bothers me.
And I will admit,
I am ethical to a fault
because of the way
I was raised.
Now, I was raised
in an East Coast,
Italian,
Catholic household, okay?
Now, I'm not Italian
'cause I'm adopted.
Uh, and I'm not Catholic
because I'm logical.
But I was raised
in that environment.
And that environment makes you
passionate to a fault
about your ethics, okay?
This is the kind of Italian,
Catholic house I grew up in.
When I was 12 years old,
my mother forced me
to watch "Goodfellas."
She for--I didn't
want to watch it.
She made me
watch it.
And the--there's a scene
in the movie
where Henry Hill,
the main character,
he gets
busted for the first time.
And he beats the rap in court
'cause he won't squeal.
And he leaves the courtroom and
goes out to the lobby,
and De Niro comes up to him.
And De Niro goes,
[as Robert De Niro]
"You learned the two greatest
"lessons in life today:
never rat on your friends,
and always, always
keep your mouth shut."
And at that part in the movie,
my mom paused the movie.
And she turned to me
and she goes,
"Did you hear that?
That's what
it's all about."
Mm, well, he committed
perjury, actually,
if you want to get down
to what it's all about.
Uh, crazy,
passionate household.
Emotional.
Very emotional.
Fights with zero filter.
Just unbridled rage
in every argument.
I've--I've gotten
so mad at my mom
in the middle of arguments,
where we're screaming,
that I'll--I would stop
and I would go,
"Ooh, what I wouldn't give,
just one time."
And my mom
wouldn't even get offended.
She wouldn't be like,
"How dare you," you know?
My mom would go,
"You and what army?"
That was her response to it.
It's psychotic.
And it was a Catholic household,
as I said too.
Very Catholic, um,
how Catholic?
This is how Catholic.
Uh, there was a framed
cross-stitch work of art
above the couch
in the living room,
uh, and it was a poem--
a Catholic poem,
and it said,
"A little boy asked Jesus,
"'Jesus,
how much do you love me?'
"And Jesus said,
'This much.'
And stretched his arms out
and died."
[laughter]
That was above the couch,
in the room
where you're supposed to
have tea with people.
We also had a statue, uh,
when you walked in
the front door, there was
a statue about this big.
There was a little table and
a statue on it about that big.
It was a bust of bloody Christ
from the crucifixion.
That was
the first thing you saw
when you walked into the house.
Like, "Ah, am I gonna like
this place?
"Oh, there's a dying Jesus
with blood and snot
all over his face, okay,
yeah, I feel welcome."
It was terrifying.
But my--I swear to God--
my best friend was Jewish,
so I would chase him
around the house
with the statue all the time
when he slept over.
"Look what you did
to me, Dan.
[spooky voice]
Look what you did, Jew!"
All right,
so that's the house.
That's the house,
and that's how I was raised.
Okay, so, uh,
about three or four years ago,
my mom got cancer.
Now, she's okay now,
she's fine,
but she had to go
through a recovery period
for a few months,
so I moved home
to try to help her
through the recovery period.
And one of the biggest rules
about cancer recovery is:
no stress.
You can't stress.
Which is gonna be tough because
this is a woman
that I've almost fist-fought
several times in my life.
So I'm just, you know,
we're cooped up in the house
and we're annoying the shit
out of each other,
but we're trying not to fight.
We're just trying
to keep it cool.
And the tension's building,
and whatever.
Then, finally, one day,
my mom goes,
"I feel good today,
let's leave--
"let's go out of the house
for the first time.
"Let's go out of the house.
It's Sunday.
Let's go to the supermarket.
We'll make a big Sunday gravy."
Italian tradition, great.
We go to the supermarket
on a Sunday in the suburbs,
which, if you've ever done that,
it's a fucking nightmare, okay?
It's horrible,
there's cars everywhere,
there's loose carts
flying all over the place.
There's kids.
It's fucking terrible.
So I'm already driving like,
"Oh, motherfucker.
We're not gonna get
a parking spot."
And I'm getting aggravated
but I'm like, "Be cool,
"'cause your--don't give
your mom cancer, again,
just be cool right now."
And there's a big, douchey,
like, SUV in front of us.
And, uh, it suddenly
just stops.
Doesn't pull over to the side,
it just stops
in the middle
of the driving lane.
And the car shuts off,
and the driver
gets out of the car,
and walks
into the supermarket.
That's it,
doesn't put his flashers on.
Doesn't go like,
"Oh, shit, dude, I'm sorry,
I'll be right back."
Nothing!
Just walk--
you ever see somebody
do an asshole-dickhead thing
like that,
and they don't
call attention to the fact
that they did an
asshole-dickhead thing?
It's like you just
saw a magic trick.
You're like,
"What the fuck just happened?
"Did he just do that?
He did that.
Wait, how did he do that?
But he did that?"
So I start honking.
I start honking and I'm yelling
even though the windows are up.
I'm yelling,
and I go, "Yeah! Hey!
You can't park here!
Hey!"
And my mom goes, "Stop it.
Stop honking right now."
And I go, "No, I won't stop it.
He shouldn't be parked--
"You can't do--did you see
what he just did?
Hey!
Hey!"
And my mom goes, "Stop it.
You're embarrassing me."
'Cause now we're out
of the house
and suddenly she has class,
all of a sudden.
And my mom goes,
"Stop it! Stop it!"
And I go, "I will not stop it!
There are rules, Mom!
Am I the only one that
gives a shit about the rules?"
And I literally start doing the
John Goodman speech
from "The Big Lebowski"
when he's in the bowling alley
with the gun.
And when you do that speech
to people, they don't go,
"Oh, 'Big Lebowski,'
right?"
They go, "What the fuck
is wrong with you?"
So I--we--we have to pull
around his truck now,
into the oncoming traffic
lane.
And it's dangerous
and whatever,
but we maneuver around
and we park.
And I'm very angry.
And my--me and my parents,
we get out of the car
and my mom and dad say,
"Come on, let's go
into the store."
And I pull a super
"Goodfellas" move right now.
I just go,
"You go ahead.
You go ahead,
I'm gonna wait right here."
Because that happens
in "Goodfellas."
There's a part in "Goodfellas"
where Ray Liotta's girlfriend
gets sexually assaulted
by the neighbor, right?
And he drives her home,
and then they see
the neighbor outside,
and she goes,
"Let's go in the house,
Henry."
He goes, "No, no, no,
no, you, you go ahead.
I'm gonna wait here."
And then he walks
across the street
and beats the neighbor's
face in with his gun.
And I've wanted
to do that so bad
in front of a girl for my
entire fucking life.
Could you imagine...
Do--do you have a boyfriend?
Uh, you love him?
You like him?
- I like him.
- Just imagine if he beat
a man's face in
with a gun in front of you--
No, you wouldn't be
making that face.
You wouldn't be making
this face,
you'd be making,
[moans] this face.
You'd be the horniest
you've ever been
in your fucking life.
It's awesome!
Anyway.
So I go, "You go ahead, I'm
gonna--gonna wait right here."
And they go in the supermarket
and I stand there,
and I just wait
for the guy.
And he comes strolling out
of the supermarket
with a six-pack.
This fucking douche bag
wasn't even going in
to get like medicine,
or some shit like that.
Like an emergency, possibly,
no--six-pack.
And he's smiling
like he's proud of what he did.
And he hops in his car.
I race to his car
and I bang on the window.
And he kind of jumps,
like, "Whoa."
And he rolls
the window down,
he's like, "What?
Wha--wha--what's up?"
And I go,
"Apologize! Right now!
Apologize, say you're sorry!"
And he goes, "What?"
And I go, "You had no right
to park here!"
"No right!
Very dangerous!
Say you're sorry
right now!"
And...
he didn't say sorry,
obviously.
He didn't come close
to an apology.
What he did say was,
"Fuck you.
Your breath smells,"
and then he drove away.
And that hurts, doesn't it?
"Your breath smells."
That hurts real deep
in the soul, doesn't it?
That's the worst
"you smell" insult there is.
There's no worse "you smell"
than "your breath smells."
I literally--this is how much
"your breath smells" hurts.
I literally would rather
be receiving
oral sex from a girl
and the girl stop and be like,
"Joe, your dick smells
really bad."
And I'd be like,
"It does? How's my breath?"
"Your breath is fine,
but your dick reeks."
"Fuck it, it's a dick, sweetie.
Keep going, wh--I don't care."
So, uh,
he drives off.
And now this is the part
in the story where I think
most people would be like,
"I've lost this round.
"Time to retreat, go inside,
and buy some sausage
for dinner tonight,
whatever."
Uh, but I decided
that I was gonna run
across the parking lot
so I could intercept his car
before it left the parking lot
because...
[stammers]
He needed to know! Okay?
So I run
across the parking lot...
[exhales]
Full speed.
Uh, he's coming,
he sees me coming.
He's not stopping
'cause he sees me coming.
So now I'm approaching his car
as he's driving past me,
and he's passing me,
not stopping.
I cock back like this,
and I punch his car
as hard as I can,
okay?
Now, some of you
are making a face like,
"Joe, that's fucking nuts."
You know what,
fuck you, okay?
Have you ever
punched a car?
Ful--when it's moving,
with all your might?
Do you know
what it feels like?
Fucking glorious,
that's what it feels like.
It is the hand of justice
hammering down.
It felt fucking great!
Until he stopped the car
and he opened the door,
and he just goes like this,
he goes,
"Let me get this straight.
Let me get this straight,
I park where I'm not supposed to
and that gives you the right
to punch my fucking car?"
And then he undid his seat belt
and he stood up.
And as he stood,
he kept screaming at me,
but I don't mean
screaming words at me.
He just literally
stood up like this:
[screams]
And, uh,
at that point I ran away
because I didn't--
I never got that far
in a confrontation before.
I was like, "That's--
that's not supposed to happen."
[laughs]
And as I was running,
I could hear him go,
he was going,
"Keep running, you pussy!"
And I--I did.
I was like, "I'm go--yeah,
"well, absolutely.
I didn't need that tip,
I know."
But I was so proud
of myself.
I really was,
I was proud of myself.
I was like, "This is what my mom
raised me to do, man."
You know, she showed me
"Goodfellas" when I was 12.
We had the
Jesus-committing-suicide thing
above our couch.
You sacrifice for what you
believe in, that's what you do.
And I couldn't wait
to tell my mom
what I did
to defend her honor,
and I went in
and I told her the whole story
right in the middle
of the supermarket.
And she--all she said was, she
looked at me and she just goes,
"You make me sick."
And I was like,
"That's not what you're, uh--
"that's not what you're supposed
to say right now.
"That's not what Ray Liotta's
girlfriend says in 'Goodfellas''
"He hands her a bloody gun
and she says she's turned on.
"But I don't want you
to say that,
"but I just mean, you know,
maybe a thank you."
And she goes,
"You make me sick."
And we started arguing
in the supermarket,
like full-on,
the argument we had been
trying to avoid for two months
because she's trying
to recover from cancer.
Here it is.
The shit is going down.
And it's not only going down,
it's going down in public.
And we are screaming,
and at the peak
of the argument--
I swear to God,
the peak of the argument,
I just go like this,
I just go,
"I am no different
than Christ!"
And my mom goes,
"What are you talking about?"
And I go, "Jesus saw
money changers in the temple!
"He went into a rage!
He flipped the tables!
That's like me punching the car!
I'm just like Christ!"
And my mom goes,
"You make me sick."
And for three days--
for three days,
I told this story
to every single person I knew.
And every time I told the story,
I made the argument
that I was not crazy.
And for three days,
every single person I knew
said to me,
"Joe, you're fucking crazy."
And for three days,
I denied it.
Until I realized,
"Everybody I know and love
"is telling me I'm crazy
and I keep saying I'm not.
That's what crazy people do."
So the point
of the story is, guys,
Jesus was fucking crazy.
[cheers and applause]
Thank you so much!
[dark electronic music]
♪